ich bin's Kevin
hey Leute
hey Leute wir sind wieder die
schlechtesten der
Strecke
Mann hi Leute ähm wir sind wieder da ihr
habt
wir waren doch immer da hey Leute hier
wieder der schlechteste Podcast
sag nein
was habe ich denn für ein Text
okay
[Musik]
es kam tatsächlich anderthalb Monate
keine Podcast Folgen online auf Spotify
und viele haben sich gefragt woran liegt
das vor zwei Wochen am Youtube Video
hochgeladen wo wir gesagt haben wir dann
auf darum ging es darum darin
in dem Youtube Video haben wir euch
gesagt dass wir unseren Spotify Vertrag
nicht verlängert haben wir äh wir haben
uns nicht mehr mit Spotify in der
Richtung identifiziert dass wir sagen
dass wir das als Partnerschaft
für den weiteren Zukunft analysieren
alles normal
so oder so meine Damen und Herren geht
der Podcast weiter wir haben die letzten
Wochen eine Menge Gespräch geführt und
haben uns jetzt mit RTL plus geeinigt
jetzt mit Stolz unsere neuen Partner
wir sind schon längst deswegen
was das coolste ist an RTL wollen wir
mal ganz kurz hier die Vorteile
Sache ist einfach dass wir in den
letzten Wochen eine Menge Gespräche
geführt haben mit RTL und die
tatsächlich genau den Weg einschlagen
wollen den wir halt einfach uns äh auch
sehen
und zwar habe ich dich von Anfang an
dass dieser Podcast kostenlos bleibt und
das bleibt dir auch das war priola Bauer
weil Luca und ich stehen nur da oben mit
den Stern weil du so geil der Grund sein
hier bei dir deswegen wollten wir nicht
dass ihr Geld für uns ausgeht und äh das
jeder den einfach kostenlos hören kann
wir bleiben komplett kostenlos jeden
Mittwoch um 20 Uhr gehen die Folgen
jetzt online also sogar noch ein paar
Stunden früher werden ja sonst mal
dieses Mittwoch auf Donnerstag
irgendwann in der Nacht gegen die Folgen
online jeden Mittwoch um 20 Uhr eine
neue Folge auf RTL plus hier online und
danach sogar eine Woche später gegen die
Folgen überall online auf Spotify auf
Apple music auf diese auf keine Ahnung
was die werden immer noch kein Assi TV
habe ich den auch direkt gesagt ne also
ich gehe gern zu RTL plus das ist
richtig geil Kölner Unternehmen manche
Leute und die verfolgen genau unsere
Ziele genau das was wir machen wollen
ich schwöre euch es sind so Kranke
Sachen geplant ich sag nur eine Sache
heißt Luft
wir freuen uns
[Musik]